All right, so we're here, are we... We want to do a cold open? Did you say bowl open? Yeah, I said bowl open. Oh, you're trying to do like a shameless post thing about the Hollywood Bowl that we're going to be at the Hollywood Bowl? On November 15th, yeah. On November 15th?
行吧，我们这就要开始了吗……我们想来个直接开场？你是说“碗开场”？对，我说的是碗开场。哦，你是在故意厚着脸皮宣传我们11月15日要去的好莱坞露天剧场吗？11月15日，对。11月15日？
Oh, you think that I'm going to sit here and do a cold open that's just a shameless plug of Smartless Live at the Hollywood Bowl on November 15th. Sean, get a grip. I'm not going to do it. Tickets are on sale now. You want me to say that? You want me to say...
哦，你觉得我会坐在这里，做一个纯粹厚颜无耻的插播广告，宣传11月15日好莱坞露天剧场的Smartless Live。肖恩，振作点吧。我才不干呢。门票现在正火热销售中。你想让我这么说吗？你想让我说……
Smartlist.com slash live. You want me to say that? Well, no, I didn't want to... I wasn't saying you should say any of that. No, I'm just saying it's gross. It's gross. All right. Because then I'm sitting here and I'm going,
Smartlist.com斜杠live。你想让我说这个？呃，不，我不是想……我不是说你应该说那些。不，我只是觉得这太恶心了。太恶心了。好吧。因为这样我就坐在这儿，然后心想，
Smartless Live at the Hollywood Bowl, November 15th. You know, tickets on sale now at smartless. com slash live. Gross, dude. Gross. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Okay, just don't insult me again,
Smartless Live好莱坞露天剧场，11月15日。你知道的，门票现已在smartless.com斜杠live上开售。真恶心，老兄。真恶心。太对不起了。太对不起了。好吧，别再侮辱我了，
Smartless Live November 15th. Let's go to the show. Also, welcome to Smartless. Yeah, obviously that. Smart Less Smart Smart
Smartless Live 11月15日。我们进入正片吧。还有，欢迎来到Smartless。对，显然是那个。Smart Less Smart Smart
Less Oh, Willie, where are you? This is my new place in New York, yeah. Do you love it? What do you mean? You got a place? Yeah. Oh, that's amazing.
Less哦，威利，你在哪儿？这是我在纽约的新住所，对。你喜欢吗？什么意思？你买房了？对。哦，太棒了。
Yeah. Where are you? Are you doing press, Willie, for your movie? No, no, no. I'm just, not yet. I'm about to, but I'm just getting sort of sorted here in my place. Sure.
对。你在哪儿？威利，你是在为你的电影做宣传吗？不，不，不。我只是，还没呢。我正准备去，但我只是在我的新家把事情理理顺。当然。
You might be seeing a friend. Oh, look, and he's got dollar bill. He's got a gambling issue. He likes to be as close to Atlantic City as possible. Without going. Wait, how are you? How is everybody doing? We haven't seen each other in like two weeks.
你可能会看到一个朋友。哦，看，他还带着美元钞票。他有赌瘾。他喜欢离大西洋城越近越好。当然不包括去那儿。等等，你最近怎么样？大家最近都怎么样？我们大概有两周没见了。
I know. I don't like it. I saw J.B. last week a couple times. We played golf and then we went to an event. We did a little charity work together. Oh, yeah. Will did some emceeing of a, very special charity event the yes charity yes what is that about so a friend uh eric eisner's charity
我知道。我不喜欢这样。我上周见过几次杰比。我们去打高尔夫球，然后去参加了一个活动。我们一起做了一点慈善工作。哦，对。威利主持了一个非常特殊的慈善活动，就是“是的慈善（yes charity）”。是的，那是怎么回事？一个朋友，呃，埃里克·艾斯纳的慈善机构
the young eisner scholars it's a really great actually look it up um it's a very worthy cause and they identify um you know kids from underserved communities who who are really smart and helps might not otherwise have access to funds for higher education or for secondary education yeah yeah it's pretty cool that is nice i was part of the tax tag group when I was a kid it was stood for talented and gifted and I couldn't do math, couldn't do anything. I don't know why I was in there.
“年轻艾斯纳学者”，其实真的非常棒，你们可以去查查。这是一个非常值得支持的事业，他们会发掘那些来自资源匮乏社区的聪明孩子，这些孩子如果不是这样的话，可能无法获得高等教育或中等教育的资金支持。对，对，这挺酷的。这确实不错。我小时候参加过一个叫做“聪明与天才”的小组，简称“塔格（tag）”，就是天才与聪明的缩写。但我根本不会做数学，什么都不会。我都不知道我为什么会在那里面。
I'd love to just kind of just send it out to the group there, just freestyle on that acronym there. I know. Will? Want to try a shot at that acronym? I mean, I do. Yeah, go ahead. Go ahead.
我真想把这个抛给那里的大家，就着那个缩写即兴发挥一下。我知道。威利？想试着发挥一下那个缩写吗？我的确想。对，说吧。说吧。
No, let's not. Now. Talent, talented and gay? Is that what it is? No. No. Oh, okay. Oh, you think I'm going to say.
不，还是别了。现在。才华横溢又是个同性恋？是这个意思吗？不是。不。哦，好吧。哦，你以为我会说……
you tight-ass gays? Does it take cheap shots? I'm not going to take a cheap shot, dude. No, thanks, I'm not walking into your bullshit. Oh, did Will just get a coffee from someone special? I might have. Was that the chef that just brought you some... Today she is.
你们这群保守的同性恋？这是在搞人身攻击吗？我才不会搞人身攻击呢，老兄。不，谢谢，我才不踩你挖的坑呢。哦，威利刚才是从哪个特殊的人那儿拿了杯咖啡吗？我可能是拿了。刚才给你拿东西的是那个厨师吗……今天她是。
Today she is. You know, everybody is so excited about your new love, Willie. I got to tell you one thing really quick. Yesterday, we visited Sean Levy, our friend Sean Levy, on the center of Star Wars yesterday. Oh my God. Did you guys even get to sleep last night? No, it was incredible.
今天她是。你知道的，威利，每个人都为你这段新恋情感到兴奋。我得赶快跟你说件事。昨天，我们在《星球大战》的片场探班了肖恩·利维，我们的朋友肖恩·利维。哦，天哪。你们昨晚甚至还有时间睡觉吗？没有，太不可思议了。
Are you going to be able to do the show with a boner? You're an hour 19 of that boner? Your lightsaber? Who needs Viagra? The people from Viagra called and they're like, hey, can we take your blood because we need to know. Let me see that picture again. Let me see that photo again.
你们录节目的时候能不支着帐篷吗？你都支着帐篷1小时19分钟了？你的光剑？谁需要伟哥？伟哥的人打电话来说，嘿，我们能抽点你的血吗，因为我们需要了解一下。让我再看一眼那张照片。让我再看一眼那张照片。
Well, you can't post it. Right, this is Sean and Scottie in the new film. Wow. How do they let you get a picture? of that? Well, we went to go to the creature shop. And you promised that you wouldn't show anybody. That's right.
好吧，你不能发出去。对，这是肖恩和斯科蒂在新电影里的造型。哇。他们怎么能让你拍下那张照片的呢？我们去了怪物特效车间。而且你保证过不会给任何人看。没错。
Right, listen to this. It's a trap, movie. It's a trap. Remember, it's a trap? Scotty, look at Scottie's making Admiral Akbar move. Isn't that wild? No, that's weird, that he's remembering
对，听着。这是个陷阱，电影。这是个陷阱。还记得吗，这是个陷阱？斯科蒂，看斯科蒂在模仿阿克巴上将的动作。这不是很疯狂吗？不，这很诡异，他居然还记得
a line of dialogue from, oh, my God, he's making the mouth. Return of the Jedi. Yeah, look at that. Oh, my God. You guys, it must have been, like, best day ever. It was incredible, it was... And Sean Levy, of course, is the greatest.
一句台词来自，哦，天哪，他在做那个嘴型。《绝地归来》。对，看那个。哦，天哪。你们俩，那一定是有史以来最棒的一天吧。太不可思议了，简直是……肖恩·利维，当然了，是最棒的。
The nicest guy. Jay, you would, Jason, you would do so well at directing one of those movies. I don't know why. Like one of those big movies. Let them know, Sean. All right, thanks, Mom. I hope my mom once said,
最好的人。杰，你会的，杰森，你非常适合导演那种电影。我不知道为什么。就像那种大片一样。让他们知道，肖恩。好吧，谢谢，妈。我妈曾经说过，
you know what, you should call Steven Spielberg and let him know you'd like to work with them. I was like, what a great idea. I know, I love stuff like that. How come you don't work with better? I remember somebody who we know, but years ago, and she said that another person we know who was very famous said to her, like,
你知道吗，你应该给史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格打电话，告诉他你想和他合作。我当时想，这主意真棒。我知道，我就喜欢这种事。你怎么不跟更好的人合作？我记得我们认识的一个人，很多年前，她说另一个我们认识的非常有名的人对她说，
you know, you should work with the Greats and the Scorsese, and then she was like, oh, okay, well, just give me their number. Sign up like the... Why didn't I think of that? Yeah, you're right. Listen, speaking of one of the Greats, guys. I love Greats.
你知道的，你应该跟伟大的导演合作，比如马丁·斯科塞斯。然后她就说，哦，好吧，那就把他的电话号码给我。就像……我怎么没想到呢？对，你说得对。听着，说到伟人，伙计们。我喜欢伟人。
My guest today had quite the historic beginning. I just wrote this last night. When she was born, Martin Luther King Jr. and his wife, Coretta paid the hospital bill. What? Didn't know this until I looked it up. What? She grew up in Georgia.
我今天的嘉宾有着相当具有历史意义的开端。我昨晚刚写了这个。她出生时，小马丁·路德·金和他的妻子科雷塔支付了医院账单。什么？我查了资料才知道这件事。什么？她在佐治亚州长大，
playing the clarinet in the school band, which I loved learning about. After graduation, she moved to New York, sold running shoes. Guess what? Chase an acting dream. On a film set 30 years ago, she picked up knitting,
在学校乐队里吹单簧管，我听到这个时觉得太棒了。毕业后，她搬到纽约，卖跑步鞋。你猜怎么着？追逐演员梦。在30年前的一个电影片场，她学会了织毛衣，
hasn't put the needles down since. Her kids once after if she was more famous than Taylor Swift. These days, she's happiest at her ranch in New Mexico. You could call her an Oscar winner. You could call her America's sweetheart. You could call her my sweetheart.
从那以后就再也没放下过织针。她的孩子们曾问她是否比泰勒·斯威夫特更有名。如今，她在新墨西哥州的牧场过得最开心。你可以叫她奥斯卡得主。你可以叫她美国甜心。你也可以叫我的甜心。
But today, I'll just call her the brilliant and always call her Julia Roberts. Yeah, I got it. Oh, my God. Julia Roberts. Hello, Julia. Oh, hi, that's so cute. She's wearing a firefighter uniform, folks.
但今天，我只想叫她聪明绝顶、永远的——茱莉亚·罗伯茨。对，我懂了。哦，天哪。茱莉亚·罗伯茨。你好，茱莉亚。哦，嗨，太可爱了。各位，她穿着消防员制服呢。
It's Boy Scouts. Oh, Boy Scouts. It's Boy Scouts. Oh, it is Boy Scouts. I did a little boy scouts. Hi. How cool that you're doing this show. Thank you, Sean, for that, for that intro.
这是童子军。哦，童子军。这是童子军。哦，真的是童子军。我也当过一点童子军。嗨。你能来做这个节目真是太酷了。谢谢你，肖恩，谢谢你做那个介绍。
All my research. It was sort of like a high coup about one's grandmother or something, the clarinet and the knitting. Wait, I didn't know you played the clarinet and the oboe. Those are the two hardest instruments. Wait a second. You don't want to get into Martin Luther King paid for the hospital bill?
我所有的研究。这听起来有点像关于某人祖母的俳句什么的，单簧管和织毛衣。等等，我不知道你还吹过单簧管和双簧管。那可是两种最难的乐器。等一下。你不想聊聊小马丁·路德·金支付医院账单的事吗？
I was going to get there too. So let's start with that. Martin Luther King paid the bill, why? They were friends with your parents. Yes. And I, not knowing the state of my family's financial situation as a brand new born baby, I guess they were maybe just going to have to smuggle me out
我正要说到那呢。那我们就从这个开始讲。小马丁·路德·金付了账单，为什么？他们跟你父母是朋友。是的。而我，作为一个刚出生的婴儿，根本不知道我家当时的经济状况，我猜他们当时可能只能在大半夜
in the middle of the night. And so this, this is. made it, we could go out the front door. I'm going to, I'm going to sound dumber than usual. Boy, this is going to be a stretch. Okay, good. What is the bill for having a baby?
把我偷偷运出去。所以这个，这个……让我们能从正门走出去。我接下来要说的话可能会比平时显得更蠢。天哪，这可真是勉为其难了。好吧，很好。生个孩子要花多少钱？
In, like, isn't that usually... In 1975. Right, like, but is it... Thanks. I'm my new favorite, Will Arnett. Yeah, he's slick. Yeah, you've got kids, you know,
在，比如，这通常难道不是……在1975年。没错，但是……谢谢。我新喜欢的威利·阿尔奈特。对，他很圆滑。对，你也有孩子，你知道的，
this is not, these are not cheap endeavors. He doesn't, he's so out of touch. He has no one. But Sags, my screen actresses guild, it's shirts. wait but isn't it all paid by the mystery elves that that are insurance isn't that they're the same people that do the laundry right julia welcome smartless welcome to you guys how jesus i love you so much for this but you know what's amazing is i am such a jason bateman fan and this up-close exchange now that we've seen each other in person
这可不是，这些都不是便宜的开销。他根本不懂，他太脱离现实了。他孤身一人。但是SAG，我的美国演员工会，那是衬衫。等等，难道不是由那些神秘小精灵，也就是保险公司全额支付的吗？难道他们不是做洗衣的那帮人吗？对不对？茱莉亚，欢迎来到Smartless，欢迎你们。天哪，我太喜欢你们做这个了，但你知道最棒的是什么吗？我真的是个杰森·贝特曼的粉丝，而现在我们面对面地近距离交流，
we've never i'm like really just like staring at you right now and you can't even tell and i'm i could spend years with you. The greatest. Do you know the first Bateman I ever truly loved is your mom? Oh, my mom. Your mom. When I met your mom. On a plane?
我们从来没有过，我现在简直就像是在直勾勾地盯着你，而你甚至都察觉不到，我可以跟你待上好几年。最棒的。你知道我真正爱上的第一个贝特曼是谁吗？是你妈妈？哦，我妈妈。你妈妈。当我遇到你妈妈的时候。在飞机上？
She is just, like, she's just such a, you just, she just has sparks that kind of shoot off. She's so beautiful and so sweet and the accent and the whole thing. The whole British accent. She nailed it. Yeah. Now, was she, because she was a flight attendant for Panic. Pan Am, did you mean it on a plane?
她简直就像是，她身上就是有一种火花在四处闪耀。她太漂亮了，太温柔了，还有那个口音以及整个人。整个英国口音。她模仿得惟妙惟肖。对。那么，她当时，因为她是泛美航空的空姐吗？泛美航空，你们是在飞机上认识的吗？
I mean, that just adds to the allure of her. With the bowler hat and everything. Yeah. Or was it on set of satisfaction? It was on set. It was, yeah. Oh, for real? Yeah. Wait, why was your mom on the set of satisfaction?
我是说，这只会增加她的魅力。带着圆顶礼帽什么的。对。还是在《满足》的片场？是在片场。是的，是这样的。哦，真的吗？对。等等，为什么你妈妈会在《满足》的片场？
Because I guess Justine wasn't yet 18 maybe, or was she, or was my mom just there visiting maybe? So, Julie was in a movie with my sister Justine way back when. It was before we were on location. We were in Los Angeles for a long time because I came out to California and I was probably there for like, at least three weeks before we went on location because we had all that band practice, you see. So cringy. If only I could have played the clarinet in that movie.
因为我猜当时朱斯蒂娜可能还没满18岁，或者说她已经满了，或者我妈妈当时只是去探班？所以，朱莉很久以前曾和我姐姐朱斯蒂娜一起拍过一部电影。那是在我们去外景地之前。我们在洛杉矶待了很长时间，因为我来到加州，大概在那儿待了至少三个星期才去外景地，因为我们有所有的乐队排练，你看。太尴尬了。要是我当时也能在那部电影里吹单簧管就好了。
Will does a great horn player. Eric clarinet. Eric clarinet, just making sure the read is nice and wet. I only do it to the theme song of Law and Order. Oh, right. Getting rid of... and I wet the reed as I'm waiting and I flip the page.
威利是个很棒的圆号手。埃里克·单簧管。埃里克·单簧管，只是确保哨片又湿润又好用。我只在《法律与秩序》的主题曲时这么做。哦，对的。摆脱……我边等边把哨片弄湿，然后翻页。
Scotty does that too all the time. You ever let the spit out at the bottom? So dumb. Yeah, careful. Spit valve. All right, so, wait, where were we? So Martin Luther King paid the bill. Yeah, yeah.
斯科蒂也总是那样。你有没有让口水从底部流出来过？太蠢了。对，小心点。排水键。好吧，等等，我们刚才聊到哪了？所以小马丁·路德·金付了账单。对，对。
That's just incredible. Isn't that wild? That's incredible, yeah. Right. And, I mean, how did they know each other, Julia? My parents had a theater school and the King kids went to that school. Oh, wow.
这太不可思议了。不是很疯狂吗？这太不可思议了，对。没错。而且，茱莉亚，他们是怎么认识的？我父母开了一所戏剧学校，金家的孩子们就去了那所学校。哦，哇。
And so then my parents became friends with them. That's amazing. So the King Kids wanted to be actors? I mean, I think one of them, and again, this is, I'm reaching back into my first days of life, but as I recall, I think one of them did have maybe some acting aspirations, but it was more than anything,
然后我父母就和他们成了朋友。太惊人了。所以金家的孩子们想当演员？我的意思是，我想他们其中一个，再次声明，这已经追溯到我生命的最初几天了，但据我回忆，我想他们中确实有人可能有一些表演方面的抱负，但比起别的什么，
I think it was just sort of, you know, hobbyist after-school weekend kind of thing to do with your kids. Wait, so your parents ran to theater school or like a theater thing. Sean, imagine the stories they, the theater stories. I can't even. Sean is going crazy now. Oh, he loves a good theater story. Sean loves a theater story. Well, no, you've done a lot of great theater.
我想这更像是一种，你知道的，放学后或周末的业余爱好，是那种和孩子们一起做的事。等等，所以你父母经营了一所戏剧学校，或者说类似戏剧相关的东西。肖恩，想象一下他们经历的故事，那些戏剧故事。我简直无法想象。肖恩现在快疯了。哦，他最喜欢精彩的戏剧故事了。肖恩最喜欢戏剧故事了。好吧，不，你演过很多精彩的戏剧。
Do you have any, like anybody ever have a heart attack in the crowd? Let's just get right to it. He usually saves these winners for the end. No, well, I have an opening night story that is pretty good, but it might be long. Maybe it's better. No, no, no, no, we've got 45 minutes left. Never too long.
你有过那种……观众席上有人心脏病发作的经历吗？我们直接切入正题吧。他通常把这些精彩的保留到最后。不，好吧，我有一个首演之夜的故事，挺精彩的，但可能会有点长。也许……不，不，不，我们还有45分钟呢。永远不会太长。
Yeah. Well, so I did a play with Bradley Cooper and Paul Rudd. I saw this one. This one with the rain. The rain, yes? Water cast! Yes. I was there.
对。好吧，我和布莱德利·库珀和保罗·路德一起演了一部话剧。我看过这部。就是那个有雨的那个。下雨的那个，对！水景剧场！对。我在现场。
Ah, bravissimo. I was there. It rained inside the theater, which was great for everyone but the people in the front row. which we discovered they were all kind of being pelted. Like, so... Julie, didn't it every day someone would go like, oh my God, I'm wet?
啊，好极了。我在现场。剧院里居然下起了雨，这对所有人来说都很棒，除了第一排的观众。我们发现他们基本上全都被淋透了。所以……朱莉，难道不是每天都有人喊“哦天哪，我湿了”吗？
It's like, well, yeah, that's the... Congrats, you go up front of receipts. Well, I don't think you go to the theater thinking that the rain in the show is going to get on you. I wouldn't think that. No, right. But, you know, we had rehearsed this play,
这就好比，好吧，对，那就是……恭喜你，你买的是前排票。好吧，我想没人会去看话剧时，以为演出里的雨会淋到自己身上。我可不会这么想。不，没错。但是，你知道的，我们排练这部话剧，
as you guys know, it goes on and on and on forever, and then it just, all you want to do is just start the thing. The opening night comes, and nerves are high, just even thinking about it, I'm getting a little short of breath. It's a beta blocker. So the play starts, Paul's on stage by himself, and it's his apartment set,
正如你们所知，它没完没了地进行下去，然后你只想赶紧把这事儿开始了。首演之夜来临了，大家都很紧张，仅仅是回想起来，我都觉得有点喘不过气来。这得吃β受体阻滞剂。于是演出开始了，保罗独自一人在舞台上，那是他的公寓布景，
and there's just this sort of like bare mattress, you know, apartment in New York, and he's reading this, he's thumbing through this book, and then there's a knock at the door. Open the door, and it's his sister, played by, yours truly clarinet player. And I come in and what's in his hand is our father's diary that he's just found and he's been reading it and he's crazed
只有一张光秃秃的床垫，你知道的，纽约的公寓，他正在读这个，他正在翻阅一本书，然后门响了。打开门，是他的妹妹，由——你们真正的单簧管演奏家——扮演。我走了进去，他手里拿的是我们刚刚找到的父亲的日记，他一直在读，他抓狂了，
and he's manic over what he's discovered and he's talking about it and he's talking about it and he tosses it on the bed as he has done 9,458 times in rehearsal. And this book skitters across the mattress hits the front of the stage and into the aisle No way.
他对自己的发现陷入了狂热，他喋喋不休地谈论着，喋喋不休地谈论着，然后他把它扔到床上，就像他在排练中做过9458次的那样。结果这本书在床垫上滑来滑去，撞到了舞台边缘，直接掉进了过道。不会吧。
Which is fine for the next four and a half minutes until I say, but... And you got to open it. Look at this. Right, right, right, right. You know, or Paul says it. He picks it up. And so we keep going, but we're looking at each other like, this has never happened before. What happens when this happens?
这倒也没事，撑到接下来的四分半钟，直到我说：“但是……”而你得把它打开。看这个。对，对，对，对。你知道的，或者保罗说。他把它捡起来。所以我们继续演下去，但我们面面相觑，心想：这以前从来没发生过啊。发生这种事的时候该怎么办？
Because this has never happened before. Meanwhile, someone working on the show who has seen this happen, sort of commando crawls down the aisle and says to the man in the front row, sir, you know, pick that up and just put it on the stage. And the man's like, what, huh, what? Paul and I are acting our little hearts out. Just pick it up, put it up on us.
因为这从来没发生过。与此同时，剧组里一个见过这一幕的工作人员，像突击队员一样沿着过道爬过来，对第一排的一个男士说：“先生，你知道的，把它捡起来，放到舞台上就行了。”那个男士一脸茫然：“啊，什么，哈，什么？”我和保罗正在全心全意地飙戏。就把它捡起来，放上去！
Look how excited it Sean is. This is one of the great stories. So the man picks it up and he kind of like doesn't quite know. I mean, I wouldn't want to touch a proper, you know. And he puts it on the stage at the exact, you couldn't have planned it better, at the exact moment that Paul goes, no, I'll read it to you,
看肖恩有多兴奋。这绝对是那些最精彩的故事之一。于是那个人把它捡了起来，他有点像……其实他不太确定。我是说，我可不想碰一个道具，你知道的。然后他把它放在了舞台上，时机简直不能再完美了——你精心设计都设计不出来——正好赶在保罗说“不，我读给你听”的那一秒，
and he picks it up. Ah, that's great. At the second, and then Paul being the amazing human being that he is, just turns and looks at the man, he goes, thank you. And everybody in the audience, you could just feel everybody just let out their breath
他把它拿了起来。啊，太棒了！就在那一秒，保罗不愧是个了不起的人，他转过身看着那个男人，说道：“谢谢你。”观众席上的所有人，你能清晰地感觉到每个人都长舒了一口气，
that we didn't realize we were holding and we sort of went on for there. This is the magic of theater, you know? Yeah. I want to get back to the beginning, Julia, because I did all this research, and it was, you know, you think you know somebody, and then you actually do read about them.
而我们之前甚至没意识到自己一直在屏住呼吸，然后我们就接着演下去了。这就是戏剧的魅力，你知道吗？对。我想回到最初，茱莉亚，因为我做了所有的这些研究，而且，你知道的，你以为你很了解一个人，然后你真的去读了关于他们的资料。
You're like, oh, I didn't know how to stuff. And then you realize, wow, nothing that I've read is actually factual. We believe in the media. So, wait, so when you were a kid, you wanted, so you played the clarinet, we covered that. You were a vet, you sold shoes. We really haven't covered that. I'm going to get double back on that. I was a doctor.
你会想：哦，有些事我真不知道。然后你意识到，哇，我读到的东西其实没有一个是事实的。我们居然相信媒体。所以，等一下，当你是小女孩的时候，你想，你吹过单簧管，我们聊过了。你想当兽医，你卖过鞋。我们还没怎么聊过这个呢。我要回过头去聊聊这个。我想当医生。
Did you hear he goes, you were a vet and you sold shoes. No, you wanted to be a vet, a veterinarian of pets. I didn't know that. That's so cool. Wait, how old were you before? before the vet thing went away? Because doesn't, every kid wants to be a vet. Everybody does.
你听到他说的话了吗，他说“你想当兽医，你卖过鞋”。不，你是想当宠物兽医。我不知道这个。太酷了。等等，在你想当兽医的念头消失之前，你多大？因为，每个小孩子都想当兽医吧？每个人都想。
I was in the 4-H club. I mean, like, I thought this was great, and it wasn't until I discovered that I don't really have a mind for science. Right, right, right. I just wanted to do the petting and, you know, I could take out a toothbrush and put some mange medicine on if necessary,
我当时加入了4-H俱乐部。我是说，我觉得这太棒了，直到我发现自己其实没有科学头脑。对，对，对。我只是想去抚摸它们，你知道的，如果有必要的话，我可以拿出一把牙刷，抹点治皮肤病的药，
but I didn't want to do the surgeries. What was the most involved thing you've ever done with an animal? Like, have you milked a cow? changed horseshoes. I've known to cow. You have? I have not changed.
但我不想做手术。你跟动物做过最复杂的事情是什么？比如，你挤过牛奶吗？换过马蹄铁。我给牛挤过奶。你挤过？我没有换过。
I've watched the ferrier do it, but I've not done it myself. What's it called? A ferrier? See, I would lose that on who wants to be a millionaire. I wouldn't know what that name. You could call me. I could call you. You would know.
我看过钉蹄匠换，但我自己没换过。那个叫什么来着？钉蹄匠？你看，如果我去参加《谁想成为百万富翁》，我在这道题上就会被淘汰。我根本不知道那个名字。你可以打电话给我。我可以打电话给你。你会知道的。
Oh my God, she'd be your security call or whatever you. I'd like to call Julia Roberts. Yeah, exactly. That'd be so good. Well, how, well, then when did the acting, when Or do you say, yeah, no, screw veterinarian. I want to be an actor. I mean, I don't know that I had that kind of moment
哦天哪，你会成为我的安全求助热线还是什么的。我想给茱莉亚·罗伯茨打电话。对，没错。那太棒了。那么，后来是什么时候开始演戏的？还是说你当时想：得了吧，去他的兽医。我想当演员。我的意思是，我不知道自己是不是有过那种时刻，
where I thought this is the path I want my life to take. I mean, my parents were artists. I have an older brother and sister. They were their artists. My sister was going to the neighborhood playhouse when I moved to New York and moved in with her. And that's when I was working at the athlete's foot on 72nd in Broadway, right?
觉得这就是我希望我的人生要走的路。我的意思是，我的父母是艺术家。我有一个哥哥和一个姐姐。他们都是艺术家。当我搬到纽约并和她同住时，我姐姐正在去neighborhood playhouse（邻里剧 Playhouse）。那时我正在72nd和Broadway交界处的The Athlete's Foot（运动鞋店）工作，对吧？
No way. That's great. No way. That's great. And I worked there for a while, and I think it was just realizing that college was not going to be in the cards for me,
不会吧。太棒了。不会吧。太棒了。我在那里工作了一段时间，我想我只是意识到上大学可能不适合我，
and I didn't really know what I didn't know what I was going to do. I mean, I had moved to New York really just because I wanted to be back with my sister because she had been gone for two years, and we were so close, and I missed her. Gone from Georgia? Yeah. But you were like, you were thinking, what,
而且我真的不知道，我当时不知道自己要做什么。我的意思是，我搬到纽约其实只是因为我想和姐姐重新在一起，因为她已经离开两年了，我们感情太好了，我很想她。离开佐治亚州？对。但你当时在想，什么，
that you were just going to go to New York and something different was going to happen? Yeah, I don't want to embarrass you, but was modeling a poll at all? I did get called in to a couple of agencies, and there was an agency called Click Models. God, I completely forgot about this. You have jogged a piece of the puzzle out of my mind.
你只是觉得你要去纽约，然后会有不一样的生活发生？对，我不想让你尴尬，但当时当模特在你的考虑范围内吗？我确实被几家经纪公司叫去过，当时有一家经纪公司叫Click Models。天哪，我完全把这事给忘了。你把藏在我脑海深处的一块拼图给唤醒了。
Yeah, let's get into it. And I did go meet a really, really nice woman there. With flick and click, wasn't it flick and click? I don't think so. No? That doesn't sound good at all. I think that's something else, yeah.
对，我们来聊聊这个。我确实去那里见了一位非常非常好的女士。叫Flick and Click，对吧？我不这么认为。没有吗？听起来一点也不像。我觉得那是别的什么，对吧。
No, no, no, I think it was. I actually think it was. No, it was click. Click modeling, click like a camera click. There's no flicking. Click and flick. So I swear to God. Anyway.
不，不，不，我觉得就是。我其实觉得就是。不，就是Click。Click modeling，Click就像相机快门的声音。没有Flick。Click和Flick。所以我向上帝发誓。不管怎样。
I think that's a massage. Okay. So, wait. So, Julia, but really to answer the question, you weren't like, okay, I'm leaving Georgia now. I'm going to be an actor, so I'm moving to New York. You were going because your sister was there
我觉得那是按摩。好吧。所以，等等。所以，茱莉亚，但 realmente 回答这个问题，你当时并不是那种“好吧，我现在要离开佐治亚州了。我要当演员，所以我要搬到纽约”。你过去是因为你姐姐在那儿，
and you've just thought... But Eric had already been working, no? He's 11 years older than I am. So he was... He had a career. Yeah. By the time I graduated from high school, but to answer your question,
而且你当时只是觉得……但埃里克当时已经在工作了，不是吗？他比我大11岁。所以他当时……他已经有事业了。是的。等我从高中毕业时，但回答你的问题，
everybody was sort of leaving home to go to school. And I did not want to be like, okay, I'll see you guys when you get back. Right, right here in my mom's apartment. Nobody worry. What about college? You said college wasn't a thing for you. that because it wasn't for me either it wasn't financially feasible and i certainly didn't have
每个人都差不多离开家去上学了。而我不想表现得像，好吧，等你们回来我再见你们。没错，就在我妈妈的公寓里。谁也别担心。大学呢？你刚才说上大学对你来说不是个选项。那是因为对我来说也不是，经济上根本不可行，而且我肯定也没有
the grades for any kind of a scholarship and should have called the king family i'd relied on them once already i i just felt like they they i didn't want them to have to support me the whole way around yeah yeah and were you to study something in college at that age had the the the veterinary thing had gone had passed right i think i probably would at that time, because you have to remember, this is 1985, I graduated from high school, and I probably would have wanted to be a home economics teacher. Oh, wow. Something I'm happy to bring back into the school system now, if asked.
能拿任何奖学金的成绩，而且我本该给金家打电话的，我之前已经靠过他们一次了，我只是觉得他们，我不想让他们一路都资助我。对，对，你在那个年纪打算在大学里学点什么吗？那个兽医的事情已经过去了，对吧？我想我当时可能会，因为你得记住，那是1985年，我高中毕业，我当时可能想成为一名家政学老师。哦，哇。如果有人邀请的话，我很乐意把这门课重新带回学校系统里。
What does that mean home economics? What does that mean? Professor Roberts. I'm glad you asked. Yeah. Like, oh, here we go. Here we go. Well, I'm an idiot.
家政学是什么意思？这是什么意思？罗伯茨教授。很高兴你问起。对。就像，哦，来吧。来吧。好吧，我是个笨蛋。
I don't know what that is. It was such a great class because it covered. It was like, yeah, sewing, but it was like sewing, mending. It was practical things. You learn how to write a check. You learn how to sew on a button. You learn how to iron a shirt. Is that when you learn knitting?
我不知道那是什么。那真是一门很棒的课，因为它涵盖了。就像，是的，缝纫，但它是关于缝纫、织补。都是很实用的东西。你学习怎么开支票。你学习怎么缝纽扣。你学习怎么熨衬衫。你就是那时候学会织毛衣的吗？
No, that I learned how to knit from the standby painter on the Pelican brief. Eric Bart taught me how to knit. Wow. The standby painter, yeah. They got a lot of kit stuff right there. Wait. Right at your disclaim. Oh, yeah, they got that bucket they sit on.
不，我是从《鹈鹕案》片场的备用油漆工那里学会织毛衣的。埃里克·巴特教我织毛衣的。哇。备用油漆工，对。他们那儿有很多这种工具装备。等等。就在你手边。哦，对，他们有个坐的桶。
It's got a bunch of stuff in there. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, I feel like I'm not a great parent for many reasons. One of them is that I haven't taught my kids how to iron, how to wash away. window without getting streaks on it. Like my parents, like I had 20 chores every weekend until the day I moved out when I was 18. Have you been good about teaching your kids?
里面有一大堆东西。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。嘿，我觉得我不是个好父母，原因有很多。其中之一就是我没教过我的孩子怎么熨衣服，怎么擦窗户才不会留下水渍。就像我的父母那样，我以前每个周末都有20项家务，直到我18岁搬出去的那天。你在教孩子这方面做得好吗？
Like, do they know how to, like, iron a shirt without wrinkling the fabric that's underneath it? How to separate it over an ironing board and put the sleeve over the little wedge portion of the board and, like, all that stuff. Like, you don't know it until you know it. You don't know it until you know it. Well, I would say there's a yes and a no here because I feel like a lot of the things. that I learned from my mom,
比如，他们知道怎么在不把下面布料烫出褶皱的情况下熨衬衫吗？怎么把它铺在烫衣板上，把袖子套在烫衣板的小尖头部分上，诸如此类的所有细节。这东西啊，你不知道就是不知道。你不知道就是不知道。嗯，我得说这有两面性，因为我觉得我从我妈妈那里学到的很多东西，
I either learned, because like you, long list of chores that started right when I got home from school. Yeah. And paused only to watch the Mike Douglas show and then right back to the chores. Mike Douglas, I love it. Phil Donahue.
我之所以学会，要么是因为像你一样，有一长串的家务活，从我放学回家就开始了。对。而且只有在看《迈克·道格拉斯秀》时才能暂停，看完又马上回去干家务。迈克·道格拉斯秀，我太喜欢了。菲尔·多纳休。
I mean... J.B., were you ever on the Mike Douglas show? No, no, I got bumped a couple times, but, no, I'm kidding. Did you? No. No. You couldn't possibly. I did do Merv Griffin, I did Oprah, what else?
我是说……杰比，你上过《迈克·道格拉斯秀》吗？没有，没有，我被取消过好几次通告，但，没有，我开玩笑的。你上过吗？没有。没有。你不可能上过的。我上过默·格里芬秀，我上过奥普拉，还有什么？
Phil Donahue? Never Phil Donahue. You know what, I slept with this guy. Uh-oh. And Chicago. Named Phil Donahue? No. What a headline this is going to be.
菲尔·多纳休？从来没上过菲尔·多纳休。你知道吗，我和这家伙睡过。哦哦。在芝加哥。叫菲尔·多纳休？没有。这会成为多大的头条新闻啊。
Sean Hay slept with Phil Donahue. Not B, Phil Donahue. Don't tell his wife. Philip Kaye, Don't know, I just slept with a guy once in Chicago. and then he ended up on the Phil Donahue show because he was the Chicago, he was a Chicago weatherman that then did porn.
肖恩·海耶斯跟菲尔·多纳休睡过。不是那个菲尔·多纳休，别告诉他老婆。菲利普·凯，不是，我只是在芝加哥跟一个家伙睡过一次，
It was so crazy in my family. You just said so many things in one sentence. I know, isn't that crazy? I slept with them once, and I remember his name. And he was a Chicago weatherman on the TV. And then one day he was on Phil Donahue because he left that career and was a porn star.
然后他最后居然上了《菲尔·多纳休秀》，因为他是芝加哥的，他是个芝加哥的气象员，后来去拍了成人片。我家里发生的事情太疯狂了。你刚才在一句话里说了好多事情。我知道，不是很疯狂吗？我跟他睡过一次，我还记得他的名字。他曾是电视上的芝加哥气象员。然后有一天他上了菲尔·多纳休的节目，因为他放弃了那个职业，成了一名成人片明星。
I was like, what? It was the craziest thing. So, wait, you had no warning on this. You were just watching your daughter. Donahue, like you do every day. Yep, that's it. There he is. And there's your guy, and he's on there because it was like a porn story that had gone wrong.
我当时想：什么？这简直是太疯狂了。所以，等等，你事先一点预兆都没有。你当时只是在看你的女儿。多纳休，就像你每天做的那样。没错，就是这样。他就在那儿。那就是你的那个家伙，他上节目是因为那是一个出了问题的成人片故事。
No, it was in America. It was like, wow, there's a gay person on television. That's it. Yeah, that was way before. Oh, Shawnee. Anyway, let's get back to you. Let's get back. You know what I want to get out? Everybody take a quick shower. So, Julia, what I don't
不，是在美国。那感觉就像，哇，电视上居然有个同性恋。就是这样。对，那是很久以前的事了。哦，肖妮。不管怎样，我们聊回你吧。我们聊回你。你知道我想说什么吗？大家快去洗个澡吧。所以，茱莉亚，我不知道，
know, and maybe, God, Wikimedia can answer this, but I'd love to hear from you, what was your first, what was your first professional acting gig. Yeah. Crime story. One episode. Is that a precursor to law and order?
也许——天哪，维基媒体能回答这个问题——但我很想听你亲口说说，你的第一份、你的第一份专业演员工作是什么。对。罪恶故事（Crime Story）。一集。那是《法律与秩序》的前身吗？
Am I being a dummy? Dennis Farina, 1950s, Michael Mann, TV show in Las Vegas. Dennis Farina, the nicest man, you could imagine. The great Dennis Frina. And... What was your character?
我是个白痴吗？丹尼斯·法里纳，20世纪50年代，迈克尔·曼，在拉斯维加斯的电视剧。丹尼斯·法里纳，你能想象到的最善良的人。伟大的丹尼斯·法里纳。而且……你演的是什么角色？
Were you a damsel in distress, or were you a bad person? I was a 15-year-old girl living with my mother, played by Hannah Cox, and her, I feel like, kind of newish husband, and he was maybe not being a good stepfather to me. No, Julia. If you catch my... Yeah, catching your dress. I'm really bringing the mood down with this.
你是个落难少女，还是个坏人？我是一个15岁的女孩，和母亲住在一起（由汉娜·考克斯饰演），还有她的，我觉得有点像是个新任丈夫的男人，他可能对我不是个好继父。不，茱莉亚。如果你懂我的意思……对，懂你的衣服。我这番话真把气氛给搞砸了。
This is no weatherman turned porn star story. But, yeah, so did that. And that was a great experience. And, you know, but... Well, you were living in New York at the time? You got Cass out of New York? Yes. Okay.
这可不是什么“气象员转行拍成人片”的故事。但是，对，所以演了那个。那是一次很棒的经历。而且，你知道，但是……好吧，你当时住在纽约吗？你是从纽约接到的戏吗？是的。好的。
So it was a big moment. It was exciting at the time, obviously. Oh, yes. Oh, it was huge. It was huge. So then you were able to sort of start your work and start to gain momentum before there was huge pressure on you to sort of pay a lot of rent and to really like declare this. This is what my career is going to be.
所以这是一个重要时刻。当时显然很令人兴奋。哦，是的。哦，太棒了。太棒了。所以你当时能够开始你的工作，并开始积聚势头，而在你身上还没有巨大的压力去赚取巨额房租，去真正宣告这就是我要从事的事业。
So you were still young enough to kind of like dip your toe in it and see if you get any traction. Is that kind of how things started? That sounds nice the way you put all that. Let's somebody jot that down. Well, you know what it is too? He likes to bundle. He's bundling it.
所以你当时还足够年轻，可以去试水一下，看看能不能激起一点水花。事情差不多就是这样开始的吗？你把这一切说得真好听。让谁来记下来吧。好吧，你知道这是怎么回事吗？他喜欢把事情串联起来。他在做串联。
Just to say, I met there was an agent. I was with my brother and his girlfriend coming from dinner one night. And, you know, they lived uptown, and so they sort of ran into some people they knew. And one of the women they were chatting with was a talent agent. And she, I don't know if she called my brother later or his girlfriend or something and said, oh, you know, does she act? And she called me into her office.
这么说吧，我遇到了一位经纪人。有一天晚上，我和我哥哥以及他的女朋友吃完晚饭出来。而且，你知道的，他们住在上城，所以他们偶然碰到了认识的人。他们正在聊天的其中一位女士是一位才华经纪人。然后她，我不知道她是后来给我哥哥打了电话还是给我哥哥的女友什么的，然后说：“哦，你知道吗，她会演戏吗？”她就把我叫到了她的办公室。
And after a nice conversation, she said, well, I can't do anything for you. But I know someone who might be able to, you know, guide you here. And she sent me to meet this man called Bob McGowan, who was from Atlantic City and was dating the star of all my children, Kim Delaney. Yes, I know. And he was just this, he seemed to me to be the nicest, this most energetic guy with time and money to spare. And he loved helping young people realize their dreams.
在进行了愉快的交谈后，她说：“好吧，我帮不了你。但我认识一个人，或许能指引你一下。”她把我介绍给了一个叫鲍勃·麦高恩的人，他来自大静市（Atlantic City），当时正在和《我的孩子们》的主演金·德莱尼交往。是的，我知道。在我看来，他简直是最善良、精力最充沛的家伙，有着用不完的时间和金钱。他喜欢帮助年轻人实现梦想。
I mean, I once went into, he became my manager. I once went into his office and said, Bob, I was at the Empire Diner today. And there's this guy, he was our waiter, and he wants to be an actor. And I said, you've got to come meet Bob. And he did, and he signed him. And that was Dylan Walsh. Oh, my God, wow. Yeah. So Bob was just this kind of incredible man who just loved being the facilitator.
我是说，我曾经去过，他后来成了我的经纪人。我曾经走进他的办公室说：“鲍勃，我今天去了帝国餐厅。那里有个家伙，他是我们的服务员，他想当演员。”我说：“你一定要来见见鲍勃。”结果他真的去了，还把他签了下来。那个人就是迪伦·沃施。哦，天哪，哇。对。所以鲍勃就是那种不可思议的人，他太喜欢当撮合者了。
You know, he just loved putting people together and that was kind of... A nice early advocate, and you stayed with him for a while? Yes. Yeah? And then what was the project that gave you the kind of momentum that would push you into sort of like, well, I need not. pursue other things. I think this might work out for at least a few years. Mystic Pizza. Yeah.
你知道，他就是喜欢把人们凑到一起，那差不多就是……一个很好的早期伯乐，你在他手下待了一段时间？是的。对吧？然后是什么项目给了你那种势头，推动你进入那种状态，比如，好吧，我不需要去追求别的东西了。我觉得这至少能行得通好几年。比萨情缘（Mystic Pizza）。对。
Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah. Didn't you get, did you get nominated for that? Or no? No. Okay. Where to go, Sean. You know, is there, and is... I did get nominated for Independent Spirit Award for Mystic Pizza.
哦，对，对。对。你没，你没因为那个获得提名吗？还是没有？没有。好吧。真有你的，肖恩。你知道，还有，有没有……我确实因为《比萨情缘》获得了独立精神奖提名。
That's what you're thinking of, Sean. That's what you're thinking of. And I lost to Jody Foster for five corners. All right. Julian, was there, was there, again, I say this a lot, but at risk of embarrassing you, was there sort of mystic pizza, you know, crime story, then mystic pizza and everything, was there a kind of a life before pretty woman and life after pretty woman? Is that fair to say?
这就是你想说的，肖恩。这就是你想说的。我输给了《小五义》里的朱迪·福斯特。好吧。朱莉，有没有，有没有——我又这么说了——冒着让你尴尬的风险，有没有“比萨情缘”之前（你知道的，比如《罪恶故事》，然后是《比萨情缘》之类的），有没有一个“《漂亮女人》之前的人生”和一个“《漂亮女人》之后的人生”的区别？这样说公平吗？
It must have changed your life in a lot of way. Well, you know, I kind of, it was a joke to start with, but it's actually completely true when people say, oh, you know, pretty woman came out, did it just completely change your life? And I said, well, I was out of town when it came out, which is the joke, but I was on location shooting, sleeping with the enemy. One of my faves. Tiny little town, thank you. And it wasn't playing at the sticky shoe theater where I was. And I remember one of the crew guys was reading USA Today, and he goes, hey, hey, your movie's in the paper.
那一定在很多方面改变了你的人生。好吧，你知道的，一开始这只是个玩笑，但当人们说“哦，你知道的，《漂亮女人》上映了，它是不是完全改变了你的人生”时，这其实是完全真实的。我说，嗯，它上映的时候我不在城里，这虽然是个玩笑，但我当时在拍摄《与敌同眠》的外景。我最喜欢的电影之一。一个小得不能再小的小镇，谢谢。而且它在我当时呆的那家寒酸的鞋子剧院里并没有上映。我记得有个剧组人员在看《今日美国》，他说：“嘿，嘿，你的电影上报纸了。”
And it just kind of said, like, you know, box office, there was like a little square and it's a pretty woman and it said what the box office was. Number meant nothing to me. I was like, hey, great. I mean, I didn't know if it was a great number, if it was a good number, if it was like. Wow.
上面大概写着，票房，有个小方框，上面写着《漂亮女人》，还写了票房收入是多少。这个数字对我来说毫无意义。我当时想：嘿，太棒了。我是说，我根本不知道这算是个伟大的数字，还是个好数字，还是像……哇。
And, yeah, so in a way, the momentum of that moment passed me by a little bit. So I think I was probably spared. Well, you're also in work mode, and that helps as a distraction to that kind of stuff, right? Do you long for those days of sort of the naivete and sort of just like, well, just kind of just doing the work and having the fun and playing make-believe and not being aware of sort of the machinations of this interesting business? Or do you like how complicated this business is?
所以，某种程度上，那个时刻的势头有点从我身边擦肩而过。所以我猜我可能免受其扰了。好吧，你当时也处于工作状态，这有助于分散你对这类事情的注意力，对吧？你是否渴望那种天真烂漫的日子，那种只是单纯地做好工作、享受乐趣、扮演假装游戏，而不去理会这个有趣的商业机器的各种阴谋诡计的日子？还是说你喜欢这个商业运作有多复杂？
Is it complicated? Well, in certain areas, in the areas that are completely unpredictable and without any sort of meritocracy, I guess. I just feel like there's so much more choice than we allow ourselves to believe. Like, I can choose to get super caught up in some of the things that really we have no control over. I have long given up reading anything.
它真的很复杂吗？嗯，在某些领域，在那些完全不可预测且没有任何任人唯贤机制的领域，我猜是这样的。我只是觉得，我们其实有比自己想象中更多的选择。比如，我可以选择对某些我们根本无法控制的事情过度操心。我早就戒掉阅读任何东西了。
Yeah. And I don't know. I don't know. You still just love doing it for what you're doing, right? It's so fun. I love it so much. It's such a goofy little job. I have a Google News Alert on you.
对。我不知道。我不知道。你还是单纯因为热爱你在做的事而在做，对吧？太有趣了。我太喜欢了。这真是一份傻里傻气的小工作。我在谷歌上设置了关于你的新闻快讯。
Just don't worry. So I'm reading all your stuff for you. And you're fine. I'm listening and I'm reading. Wait, so when steel, so I, so you were filming Sleeping with the Enemy before Steele Magnolias? No, Steele Magnolias was first. So I filmed Steel Magnolias.
别担心。所以我一直在替你阅读你所有的东西。你很好。我在听，也在读。等等，所以当《钢木兰》……不对，你是先拍了《与敌同眠》，然后才拍《钢木兰》吗？不，是先拍《钢木兰》。所以我拍了《钢木兰》。
I filmed Mystic Pizza and then I, don't you have my IMD help you? Yeah, I know, but I want you to tell it. Then I did Steal Magnolias. Yeah. Then I did Pretty Woman. Yeah. Then I did Flatliners.
我拍了《比萨情缘》，然后我——难道你没有用我的IMDb帮我理清吗？对，我知道，但我希望你亲口说出来。然后我拍了《钢木兰》。对。然后我拍了《漂亮女人》。对。然后我拍了《别闯阴阳界》。然后我拍了《与敌同眠》。然后，你知道的，你知道《钢木兰》里的那个情节吗？斯科蒂得了糖尿病，当你演那场戏时，斯科蒂在现实生活中也经历过类似的一场戏，我大概在七、八年前才第一次看《钢木兰》。
Then I did Sleeping with the Enemy. And then, you know, you know the thing in steel magnolia is Scotty's diabetic and when you had that scene Scotty had a scene like that in real life and I had I only watched Steel Magnolia is like for the first time like seven, eight years ago
然后我拍了《与敌同眠》。然后，你知道，你知道《钢木兰》里的那个桥段，斯考蒂患有糖尿病，当你有那场戏时，斯考蒂在现实生活中也经历过类似的情景，而我——我直到七、八年前才第一次看《钢木兰》。
crazy. No, thanks for the support. She's seven years ago. Oh my God, I've seen sleeping with the enemy like 17 times but I have, I've seen it a billion times but no the No, yeah, but that scene was so real So Scotty's flatlining, go ahead.
太疯狂了。不，谢谢你的支持。那是七年前的事了。哦，天哪，我看了《与敌共眠》大概有17遍，不过说真的，我看了有上亿遍。不，不是，对，但那一幕太真实了。所以斯科蒂（Scotty）的生命体征平稳了，继续吧。
That scene was so real when you had the diabetic thing and when we first started dating we've been together almost 20 years and he would be he would do let's go on to the next question good Lord I feel like you're circling the airport
那一幕太真实了，当你有糖尿病发作那段时——我们刚开始约会时，我们在一起快20年了，他会……他会做……咱们进入下一个问题吧，天哪，我觉得你一直在机场盘旋，
you're about to take the landing here down because you said has anything crazy ever happened during a play but during screening of steel magnolias there were a lot of reports of people having sort of like physical responses
你快要着陆了，因为你刚才说在话剧演出期间有没有发生过什么疯狂的事，但在放映《钢木兰》期间，有很多报道说人们有那种身体上的反应，
to watching you do that? Wow. Yeah. People who are predisposed to these outbursts, these conditions. Julia, I'm going to tell you a true story. Trouer than Sean and Scotty, I guess, flatlining watching Steelman. I don't know what happened, but. No, no.
比如看你表演那个？哇。是的。那些容易出现这种情绪爆发、这种状况的人。朱莉娅，我要告诉你一个真实的故事。比肖恩和斯科蒂还要真实，我猜，看《钢木兰》时生命体征平稳。我不知道发生了什么，但是。不，不。
He almost died, and it was, but he was going into that kind of shaking kind of crazy thing. Here we come. years down. I think 90 years down. No, it's fine. It was just amazing. It was amazing, an amazing performance and how true to life that actually really was. Thank you.
他差点死掉，那是……但他当时进入了那种发抖的疯狂状态。我们来啦。年复一年。我想是90年以后。不，没关系。这太棒了。太棒了，这是一场精彩的表演，那实际上是多么地贴近生活啊。谢谢你。
Thank you. I'm with you. Someone just told me that there's, I think, a smoothie place or something on Fire Island and they have a smoothie called Drink Your Juice, Shelby. Ah, yeah, very good. I want to say, I'm going to say, Will, any Fire Island smoothie jokes? Hey, Jason. I just like to tee them up, you know.
谢谢你。我懂你。刚刚有人告诉我，火岛（Fire Island）好像有一家冰沙店什么的，他们有一种冰沙叫“喝你的果汁吧，谢尔比”。啊，对，很好。我想说，我要说，威尔，有什么关于火岛冰沙的笑话吗？嘿，杰森。我只是抛个梗，你知道的。
I'm going to say December 1991. Thank you, Mary Lou. I'm in Stowe. Mary Lou Henner, I'm with you. Skiing. Skiing with my dad and my brother. Oh, I went to snow, Vermont. And I saw you having breakfast in this little breakfast place.
我要说1991年12月。谢谢你，玛丽·露。我在斯托（Stowe）。玛丽·露·亨纳，我和你在一起。滑雪。和我的爸爸和哥哥一起滑雪。哦，我去了佛蒙特州的斯托。我看到你在那个小早餐店吃早餐。
I just remembered that. I haven't thought about this in years. And you were with a bunch of people, and you were having breakfast. And, yeah. What did I eat? Not for nothing. Wow. And mine was bad?
我刚刚想起来。我已经好几年没想过这个了。你和一群人在一起吃早餐。然后，是的。我吃了什么？不是白说的。哇。我的很糟糕吗？
Yeah. Well, it just sounds like a great stories today. Mine was short. that's true yeah and I was only there one time Stowe-V-Mont The one time you were in Stove, there you go
是的。嗯，听起来今天都是很棒的故事。我的很短。确实，是的，我只去过一次斯托，佛蒙特州。你唯一一次在斯托，就是这样。
Can we talk about I think I mean your career is just incredible and enormous and something we can spend I want to talk to the extent you're comfortable I think one of the greatest things
我们能谈谈——我觉得，我是说，你的职业生涯简直不可思议、蔚为壮观，这是我们可以花时间……我想在你能接受的范围内聊聊，我觉得你人生中最好的事情之一，
in your life is your marriage like forever and that's not common and this guy is like a great guy incredibly talented i'm like i really dork out over cinematographers um can you would you are you comfortable talking about like is there is there is there a key is there a secret i mean this is like a great
就是你的婚姻，长长久久，而这并不常见。这人是个好家伙，才华横溢，我真的很崇拜摄影师。嗯，你能……你愿意、你能够聊聊吗？比如，有什么秘诀吗？有什么诀窍吗？我的意思是，这是一个很棒的故事，
story and how you met danny motor everybody danny motor um well first let me just say this is that he i mean i really liked your podcast he loves this podcast and i was trying get him to be on it without telling him so that he would just like be tuning in and all of a sudden there's this old lady's voice but it didn't. He saw my agenda book and he was like smartless. I love that.
以及你是怎么遇到丹尼·莫德（Danny Moder）的，大家都知道丹尼·莫德。嗯，首先让我这么说，他——我的意思是，我真的很喜欢你的播客，他很喜欢这个播客，我曾试图在不告诉他的情况下让他上这个节目，这样他就会收听，然后突然出现一个老太太的声音，但没成功。他看到了我的日程本，然后他就说：“聪明无知（SmartLess）”。我真喜欢这个。
I remember seeing you at a charity event and you were with Danny and you just looked him and you go and you looked at me and you go isn't he the best? I just love him and it was so sweet. I just thought that was the sweetest. What's the secret, darling? I know, I'm getting all sweaty.
我记得在一次慈善活动上见过你，你和丹尼在一起，你看着他，然后你看着我，你说：“难道他不是最好的人吗？”我太爱他了。太甜了。我当时觉得那是世界上最甜蜜的事。秘诀是什么，亲爱的？我知道，我紧张得出汗了。
You know, it's really... You seem like your buddies. Yeah? Well, he's my best friend. Yeah, there you go. And, but also the only person I want to make out with. So I think it's that combination of things is... Amen.
你知道，这真的很……你们看起来像哥们儿。是啊？嗯，他是我最好的朋友。对，就是这样。而且，他也是唯一一个我想和她亲热的人。所以我觉得是这些因素的结合……阿门。
Yeah. But you know what? Here's the thing, because you just don't know. You never want to give all the credit away to one person and say, I owe it all to this one person. but honestly. This is the section about Kevin Huvain. Here we go.
是的。但你知道吗？事情是这样的，因为你根本不知道。你永远不想把所有的功劳都归功于一个人，然后说，我这一切都归功于这个人。但老实说。这是关于凯文·休维恩（Kevin Huvane）的部分。我们开始吧。
I wanted to talk about Danny. For Tracy, he's an agent. He's a big agent in Hollywood. But 25 years later, I mean, I just think, gosh, my life could have gone off the rails a hundred different ways in the last 25 years were it not for finding my person. I don't know how, I don't know what small nation of people I saved in a former life. I feel the same way, yeah. Did you guys work on a project together?
我想谈谈丹尼。对于特拉西来说，他是个经纪人。他是好莱坞的大经纪人。但25年后，我是说，我只是觉得，天哪，在过去的25年里，如果不是找到了我的真命天子，我的人生可能会有一百种不同的方式走向崩溃。我不知道为什么，我不知道我在前世拯救了什么国家的人。我也有同感，是的。你们一起合作过项目吗？
Is that how you met? Yes, we met on a movie called The Mexican. Oh, yeah. Good looking movie. And he was on that movie, and I, they had been shooting for about three weeks, and he, God, what, was he, he was the focus puller in that movie? Yeah.
你们就是这样认识的吗？是的，我们在一部叫《墨西哥人》的电影里认识的。哦，是的。一部养眼的电影。他那部电影里，我……他们已经拍了大约三个星期了，他，天哪，什么，他是……他是那部电影的跟焦员？是的。
And he and Brad were always next to each other and always talking. Right. Brad Pitt from my sister. So I come in and I'm like the new one and I'm like, you know, they're talking about, I don't know, a new, you know, record that's come out or something. I'm like, oh, I love that.
他和布拉德（Brad）总是挨着坐，一直在聊天。没错。我姐夫布拉德·皮特。所以我走进去，就像是个新人，你知道，他们在聊天，我不知道，聊什么新出的唱片之类的。我就说：“哦，我喜欢那个。”
Trying to jump in there. I love that band. Oh, yeah. I kind of start humming it and be like, oh, yeah. Yeah, oh, yeah. I know. And they're just like so locked into each other. I was just looking for a wait and the conversation.
试图插话。我喜欢那个乐队。哦，是的。我开始跟着哼唱，然后说：“哦，是的。没错，哦，是的。我知道。”他们俩聊得那么投入。我只是在等一个插话的机会。
And not realizing that one day this man that I was just trying to have a conversation with would be my husband. Wow. That's so cute. And then you finally had a conversation. We had a conversation and he has not gotten me to shut up in 25 years. I love that. I love that. But the fact that you're able to schedule and work out all these kind of, you know,
完全没有意识到，有一天，这个我正试图和他搭话的男人会成为我的丈夫。哇。太可爱了。然后你们终于聊上了。我们聊上了，而且在25年里，他都没能让我闭嘴。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。但你们能安排并处理好所有这些……你知道的，
You go away, he goes away, let's meet up every couple of weeks. Like, it's got to be just so difficult. I know, high class problems, listener. These are high class problems, but you want to know something? We have in all these years, and we have three awesome kids, and only one time in our lives, and the kids were probably, they were all under five, for sure, and now they're all in college. But there was one time.
你出差，他出差，每隔几周见一次面。这一定非常困难。我知道，这是“高档问题”，听众朋友们。这些都是“高档问题”，但你想知道吗？这些年来，我们有了三个超级棒的孩子，在我们一生中只有一次——当时孩子们可能都不到五岁，绝对是这样，而现在他们都上大学了。但有那么一次，
when I was doing Eat, Pray, Love, and Danny was shooting a movie in Detroit. And we were apart... So you were in India, right? For seven weeks.
当我正在拍《美食、祈祷和恋爱》时，丹尼在底特律拍电影。我们分居了……所以你在印度，对吧？呆了七周。
Oh, wow. That's long. And, I mean, I was lucky because I at least had the kids with me. But he, and there was just no way, even one time I did have three days off in a row. And I thought, oh, great, we can, you know,
哦，哇。真够长的。而且，我很幸运，因为我至少把孩子带在身边了。但他……而且根本没办法，甚至有一次我确实连续休了三天假。我想，太好了，我们可以，你知道的……
And even if I went as the crow flies from New Delhi to Detroit, it would, we could have hugged and I'd have to turn around. Like it was so, it was seven weeks. And when he finished and he came and joined us and we were just like, wow, that will never work. All right. You said the kids are in college now. How recent have you become an empty nester? It's been two and a half weeks.
而且就算我从新德里“直线飞行”到底特律，我们也只能拥抱一下，然后我就得转身回去了。真的就是这样，那是七周。等他拍完来和我们汇合时，我们俩都觉得：“哇，这样绝对行不通。”好啦。你刚才说孩子们现在都上大学了。你成为空巢老人多久了？两周半了。
Oh, my God. Wow. So I just sent my first one away, but it was just down the street to USC, so I'm happy about that. But I'm not anticipating doing well when the 13-year-old goes away in five years and being empty, empty. How are you doing it? Yes, but you and your wife are crazy about each other. So it's all going to be okay. I think it's when the kids leave and you turn around and you're like, who are you?
哦，天哪。哇。所以我刚把第一个孩子送走，但学校就在街区那头的南加州大学（USC），所以我对此挺高兴的。但我无法想象，五年后当13岁的孩子也离开，家里彻底空了的时候，我会不会崩溃。你是怎么应对的？是的，但你和你太太深爱着彼此。所以一切都会好起来的。我觉得是当孩子离开，你转过身去，心想：你是谁？
What are you still doing here? That's when you run into troubles. You were supposed to go too, yeah. Yeah, like, I'm still here? Yeah, that's amazing. I love that you revealed just in that, you know, you're the first cover star of the brand new 72 magazine, which is really cool.
你怎么还在这儿？这时候你就会遇到麻烦了。你应该也一起走才对，对吧。对，就像，我还在这儿？天哪，太神奇了。我很高兴你透露了这一点，你知道的，你是全新杂志《72》的第一位封面明星，这真的很酷。
And you revealed, George Clooney interviewed you, and you revealed your dream seven-person dinner guest list, which I love. And the first person you named was Danny, which was great. Oh, that's good. And Jesus, and Virginia Woolf and Joni Mitchell. It was a great list. I loved it.
你还透露，乔治·克鲁尼采访了你，你透露了你梦寐以求的七人晚宴嘉宾名单，我超喜欢。你点名的第一个人是丹尼，这太棒了。哦，那挺好。还有耶稣、弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫和琼尼·米切尔。这是一个很棒的名单。我很喜欢。
Yeah, I mean, it's so funny because whenever someone asks you a question like that, and you have to, you know, rapid fire answer and you feel like and then afterwards you go like oh that'd be a good dinner party and then of course for the rest of the day it's like oh but what it oh it should have been this person and what about that person and yeah yeah um but i think i did i think i i mean wouldn't it jesus coming to dinner yeah right what would i ask him what would i ask him today you know versus like last year or something yeah uh george would be a good guest at that right
是的，我是说，太搞笑了，因为每当有人问你这样的问题，你必须，你知道的，连珠炮似地回答，你会觉得……然后事后你会想，哦，那会是个很棒的晚宴，当然接下来一整天你都会想，哦，但应该是这个人，那个人怎么样呢？对，对，嗯……但我猜我做了，我想我——我的意思是，耶稣来吃晚宴难道不棒吗？对吧。我会问他什么？我今天会问他什么（而不是像去年或者别的什么时候）？对，嗯……乔治会是个好嘉宾，对吧？
george cluny yeah yeah i can talk yeah very good good storyteller. Great storyteller. Yeah, he told us that classic about crapping in the cat box. Oh, my, it's one of the greatest stories of all time. Yeah, that is, and I hadn't heard it until he came out of the pocket.
乔治·克鲁尼，对，对，我很会聊天，非常棒。很会讲故事的超级大咖。真的，他给我们讲了那个关于在猫砂盆里拉屎的经典故事。哦，天哪，这是史上最棒的故事之一。对，那是，在他拿出来讲之前我都没听说过。
It was great. But even better than hearing George tell it is Richard telling it, because Richard's voice. Richard's voice is so. Oh, Judy! Yeah. He's great. I love that guy.
太棒了。但听理查德讲这个故事比听乔治讲还要精彩，因为理查德的声音。理查德的声音太……哦，朱迪！对。他太棒了。我太喜欢那家伙了。
And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Wait, so I read that you saved a seven-page love letter from Danny to someday show your kids and have you showed your kids? That's the first letter he ever wrote me. I have all the letters. And in fact, someone gave us a great present many years ago. These two beautiful sort of ceramic earthen pots.
我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。等等，所以我看到你保留了丹尼写的一封七页纸的情书，打算有一天拿给你的孩子们看，你给孩子们看过了吗？那是他写给我的第一封信。我所有的信都留着。事实上，多年前有人送了我们一份很棒的礼物。这两个漂亮的陶瓷陶罐。
And the lid on one pot inside. is painted love letters to Julia from Danny, and the other one is to Danny from Julia. And so there's all these, like, we're just shoving stuff in there for years. There's just no telling what's at the bottom of these jars. Right. But, yeah, we are, we're big on paper in our house.
其中一个罐子的盖子里面，画着“丹尼写给朱莉娅的情书”，另一个则是“朱莉娅写给丹尼的情书”。所以有所有这些，就像，我们多年来一直在往里面塞东西。根本说不清这些罐子最底下到底有什么。没错。但是，是的，我们很重视纸质信件，在我们家是这样。
And our kids are now, too. So it's nice to, like I opened a book the other day, there was a postage from my oldest son. in the handwriting of maybe like a seven-year-old, which is not too dissimilar from his handwriting now, but I could see the time. And it just said, Mom, I'm so, so, so, so, so, so sorry.
我们的孩子现在也是。所以感觉很好，比如我前几天打开一本书，里面有一张我大儿子的便条。是用大概七岁小孩的笔迹写的，和他现在的笔迹差别不大，但我能看出那是以前的时光。上面只写着：“妈妈，我真的、真的、真的、真的、真的、真的非常抱歉。”
Uh-oh. What did I do? And I thought, oh, I wish I had written on the other side of the Post-it. Oh, what the grievance was. Other than your wedding day and the birth of your gorgeous children, could pick one year to relive, what would it be? Because it was so great. Because it was so great? Yeah. I love that. Somebody just asked me that the other day. A whole year. Sean's coming with a classic. A whole year? Or a day, or is there one day? Don't back off. Don't back off, Sean.
噢噢。我做了什么？我想，天哪，真希望我在便条的另一面写下来。哦，到底是什么委屈。除了你的婚礼和生下你可爱的孩子之外，如果你能选择重温一年，会是哪一年？因为太棒了。因为太棒了？对。我喜欢这个。刚才刚有人问过我这个问题。整整一年。肖恩要抛出经典回答了。整整一年？还是一天，或者有没有哪一天？别退缩。别退缩，肖恩。
No, mine was any day, any year in college. I just loved my college life. I loved it. I'd love to see that. I was a crazy person. It was great. You know, I don't know. I'm just thinking any year that I could go back and spend before my father passed away, he passed away when I was young. And so I feel like even though I don't kind of say, oh, this was a great year and I want to relive that year,
不，我的意思是大学里的任何一天、任何一年。我太喜欢我的大学生活了。我爱极了。我很想看看那个。我以前是个疯子。太棒了。你知道的，我不知道。我在想，任何一年，如果我能回到我父亲去世前去陪伴他——他去世时我很年轻。所以我觉得，尽管我不会说：“哦，这是伟大的一年，我想重温那一年”，
just to have any year with the knowledge that this is special because it's not going to last. Was he the one that was running the theater? school was it was your dad and your mom together it was my dad and my mom together but i think my dad was was the was the captain was he alive long enough to start to uh experience some of your um your momentum no i was a child very child yeah very young he would have loved it yeah did that did that i mean well that's just a dumb question but like what did you how did you where did that affect my life i mean how does this hold you back now no because my dad i mean i guess my dad i mean i
但只要能和父亲共度任何一年，并带着“这一切很特别，因为不会长久”的意识就行。他是那个经营剧院的人吗？学校是由你爸爸妈妈一起经营的吗？是我爸爸妈妈一起经营的，但我认为我爸爸是……是主心骨。他活到能看到你……体验到你的一些势头吗？没有，我还是个孩子，非常小的小孩。对，非常年轻。他会喜欢它的。对，这……这……这真是个蠢问题，但比如，你是怎么……这怎么影响了我的生活？我的意思是，这怎么会拖累你呢？不，因为我爸爸——我想我爸爸——我……
I haven't thought about it either. My dad left. My dad left when I was like five or six. He did? How? He just literally walked out the door. He did? With the keys or?
我其实也没怎么想过。我爸爸走了。我爸爸在我五六岁的时候就走了。真的吗？怎么走的？他真的就这样夺门而出了。真的吗？带着钥匙吗？
Yeah. Surely he came back. You guys are cruel. Was there a vehicle involved? We got to have one of those things like Stern with the little sound things. Just a screeching tires. Anytime his parents, oh, you're right. We need Fred here to do that.
对。他肯定回来了。你们太残忍了。当时有交通工具参与吗？我们得弄一个像霍华德·斯特恩（Stern）节目里那种带音效的东西。就是轮胎刺耳的摩擦声。每当提到他父母……哦，你说的对。我们需要弗雷德（Fred）来做这个。
No, but there was something like, With the fact, I think growing up is like... Abandonment can be funny. Yeah. It has to be. If you didn't laugh, you'd cry. I think that that's the kind of, you know... Yeah.
不，但有那种感觉……事实上，我觉得成长就像是……被抛弃也可以是搞笑的。是的。必须得是这样。如果你不笑，你就会哭。我觉得那种……对。
I mean, my mom had Alzheimer's too, which is once I cried... So she doesn't remember him, lady. Oh, my God. You guys. That's the good news. I cannot play like this. We find the good in everything, Julie. You have to.
我是说，我妈妈也有老年痴呆症，一旦我哭了……所以她不记得他了，女士。哦，天哪。你们这群人。这是好消息。我没法这样演下去了。我们在每件事中都能找到美好的一面，朱莉娅。你必须这么做。
This is how we love. Julia, this is how we love. This is how we love. And also, but... But if I didn't make jokes or laugh about him, I cried for three years straight about my mom having Alzheimer's. So she's passed away since then, but I cried and cried and cried and tried to take care of, and every one of our family members, try to care of it.
这就是我们相爱的方式。朱莉娅，这就是我们相爱的方式。这就是我们相爱的方式。而且，但是……但如果我不开玩笑或不拿他当笑料，我就会为了我妈妈患老年痴呆症这件事连续哭上三年。所以她在那之后已经去世了，但我哭啊哭啊哭，试图照顾她，我们家的每一个人都在努力照顾她。
And then after a while, you're just, you have to have some levity. So anyway, one time I was, she was at this, this memory care place, and there was a band there, there was a live band, and I was sitting with Scotty and his mom. What a gig. Yeah, and. Like some of the top bands. Like some people who won't remember you.
然后过了一会儿，你就会……你必须保持一些幽默感。总之，有一次我……她在一家记忆护理中心，那里有一个乐队，是一个现场乐队，我和斯科蒂还有他妈妈坐在一起。真是一场演出。对，而且……就像一些顶级的乐队。就像有些根本不记得你的人。
They're like, should we play some of the old hits? It doesn't matter. They don't know. It's new to them. Everything's new to them. You can play a Beatles song and say, we just wrote this. That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying.
他们会问：“我们要不要演奏一些老歌？”没关系。他们不记得。对他们来说一切都是新的。对他们来说一切都是新鲜的。你可以演奏一首披头士的乐队的歌，然后说：“这是我们刚写的。”这就是我想说的。这就是我想说的。
That's why you have to make light of it because otherwise you'll die crying. Okay. So anyway, there's a band. I called this one Satisfaction. I just rode it in the car the way here. So we're sitting there, and I'm sitting there with Scotty and Scottie's mom. And all of a sudden, Scotty's mom, who's one of the sweetest people in the world,
这就是为什么你必须把事情看淡，否则你会哭死的。好吧。所以无论如何，有个乐队。我把这个叫做《满足》。我来的路上在车里刚写好。我们坐在那儿，我和斯科蒂以及斯科蒂的妈妈坐在一起。突然间，斯科蒂的妈妈——世界上最甜美的人之一，
she gets up and starts dancing. She says to my mom, Mary, she's like, Mary, come on and dance. And she's like, yeah. And she's like, she's going to get up and then. She tries to grab me. And she goes, Sean, come on, let's dance. I go, Mom, I don't want to dance. There's all these people watching in this room.
她站起来开始跳舞。她对我的妈妈玛丽说：“玛丽，来跳舞吧。”我妈就说：“好啊。”她就像是，她要站起来，然后……她试图抓住我。她说：“肖恩，来吧，我们跳舞。”我说：“妈，我不想跳舞。屋里有这么多人看着呢。”
And there's a dance floor. I'm like, no, Mom, I don't want to watch. She goes, come on, let's stand. I go, no, Mom, I don't want. She goes, don't be such a pussy. And I was like, what? She would have never said that. Did you die laughing, though?
还有一个舞池。我说：“不，妈，我不想看。”她说：“来吧，我们跳舞。”我说：“不，妈，我不想。”她说：“别当个娘娘腔（pussy）。”我当时就想：什么？她绝对不会说这种话。你当时笑得要死吧？
Oh, my God, I laughed. Did you dance with her? No. I was too embarrassed. Sean. I know, I wish I could now, blah, blah, blah. So anyway, no, she was sweet, though. You and Tracy must have laughed up that one.
哦，天哪，我笑疯了。你跟她跳舞了吗？没有。我太尴尬了。肖恩。我知道，我希望我现在能，巴拉巴拉。所以总之，不，她其实很甜的。你和特拉西肯定拿这个笑了很久。
Oh, God. So my whole family, we love. loved her so much. Anyway, so this is a good one I wrote down because somebody asked me this the other day. If you had to marry, this is for everybody. Julia, if you had to marry a woman, guys, if you had to marry a guy,
天哪。所以我的整个家族，我们都太爱她了。总之，这是我记下的一个好问题，因为前几天有人问过我这个问题。如果你必须和一个女人结婚——这是问大家的。朱莉娅，如果你必须和一个女人结婚，伙计们，如果你必须和一个男人结婚，
me if I had to marry a woman, who would it be? Mine would be Carrie or Raina or Allie or Jen or Amanda. I would marry Jason's wife Amanda. If you had to marry a girl. That's a lot of people, and I didn't even make the top 10.
如果我必须和一个女人结婚，会是谁呢？我的会是凯瑞、雷娜、艾莉、珍或阿曼达。我会娶杰森的妻子阿曼达。如果你必须和一个女孩结婚。那可是很多人，而且我甚至都没进前十。
Hang on, I'm not done. Julia. Okay, there you go. I would marry either Francis McNorman or Kate Blanchett or Emma Thompson. Nice.
等等，我还没说完。朱莉娅。好吧，给你。我会娶弗兰西斯·麦克多曼、凯特·布兰切特或艾玛·汤普森中的一个。不错。
Wow. Those are good answers. Those are pretty good. There's more, but I'm limiting myself to three. Yeah. Guys? I would marry one of these two guys
哇。这些都是好答案。相当不错。还有更多，但我把自己限制在三个。好吧。伙计们？我会娶这两个家伙中的一个
because of the formula you were talking about before, which is you've got to marry a friend if you wanted to last. that's right i've always i've always thought and so far i'm right because i i do i do really like that amanda i'd marry i'd same thing i'd marry one of these two guys because they're guys that i love and that i like and jason we'd be able to share our golf clubs yeah because we've like i tried his wedge the other day is great and also jason because i'd love to marry a known
因为你之前说过那个公式，那就是如果你想让婚姻持久，你就得和朋友结婚。没错，我一直——我一直这么认为，到目前为止我是对的，因为我确实——我真的很喜欢那个阿曼达，我会娶——同样地，我会娶这两个家伙中的一个，因为他们是我爱、我喜欢的家伙，杰森，我们就能共用高尔夫球杆了，对，因为我们就像——我前几天试了他的挖起棒，太棒了；还有杰森，因为我很想娶一个公认的
bottom um you don't want to have to do any fighting right no negotiating right and uh no i truly truly I would be one of these two guys. I love these guys so much. I love you guys, too. I want to hear about your new thingy, Julia. So I just watched it last night. I couldn't wait talking about. Oh, you did.
受（bottom）……嗯，你不想经历任何争吵吧？不需要谈判对吧？而且，嗯，我真的、真的会选这两个家伙中的一个。我太爱这些家伙了。我也爱你们。我想听听你的新玩意儿，朱莉娅。我昨晚刚看完。我迫不及待地想谈谈。哦，你看过了。
They're locked. They're locked, Sean. So watch the notes. I loved it so much. Wait, so what is it? After the Hunt. It's called After the Hunt. I just watched it last night.
它们锁定了。肖恩，它们锁定了。所以注意看那些笔记。我太喜欢了。等等，那是什么？《猎场》（After the Hunt）。片名叫《猎场》。我昨晚刚看完。
What an awesome, dark, complicated character you're playing. As always, I believed every moment, every word coming out of your mouth. Yeah, you never suck. And it was crafted in such a way that reminded me of, and now after the hunt will be on that list, doubt. What's the other one? Like, conclave after the hunt. Like, they're all kind of brilliantly made, brilliantly performed.
你扮演的角色是多么棒、多么黑暗、多么复杂啊。一如既往，你说的每一个字、每一个瞬间我都深信不疑。对，你从不让人失望。而且它的构思方式让我想起了——现在《猎场》也会加入那个名单——《虐童疑云》（Doubt）。另一个是什么？就像《秘密会议》（Conclave）和《猎场》一样。它们都拍得非常出色，表演也极其精湛。
Your performance was incredible. And the end, I was like, because the whole time I'm like, what's going on? What is happening? And then the reveal was so cool. I mean, crazy, but cool. Yeah. Anyway, thanks for coming.
你的表演太不可思议了。最后，我当时想，因为整个过程我都在想，到底怎么回事？发生了什么？然后那个反转太酷了。我是说，疯狂，但很酷。好吧，谢谢你来。
Julie, you must be proud of it. It sounds like a pretty high level. What drew you to the material? Luca Guadino, who is just, he's... He did call me by your name. I mean, tons of great movies. He is so wonderful as a person and so innovative and the most curious person I've ever met.
朱莉娅，你一定为它感到骄傲。听起来水平相当高。是什么吸引你加入了这个项目？卢卡·瓜达尼诺，他简直是……他拍过《请以你的名字呼唤我》。我是说，有无数部伟大的电影。他作为一个人是如此美妙，如此富有创新精神，是我见过最好奇的人。
He's so curious about people and why we do the things we do. and why we don't do things and just every detail of every everything he is, there's nothing that you're seeing that hasn't been specifically chosen in this shade of color and this statue and this painting being slightly askew or, you know, whatever.
他对人们充满好奇，好奇我们为什么会做我们所做的事，为什么不做某些事，以及每一个细节的方方面面。你所看到的没有任何东西不是经过专门挑选的，比如这种色调、这个雕像、这幅稍微有些歪的画，或者，你知道的，诸如此类。
I mean, it's just really, it's so... Well, there's a really cool moment too when you guys, you and... Oh, forgive me, Aya, right? Ayo. Iowa debris. So sorry. So when you and I are, it's kind of towards the end and you have this incredible scene outside of this building.
我是说，这真的太……嗯，还有一个非常酷的时刻，就是你们，你和……哦，原谅我，阿亚，对吧？阿约（Ayo）。阿约·艾德拜利（Ayo Edebiri）。非常抱歉。所以当我和你……这有点像是在接近尾声的时候，你们在这栋大楼外面有一场不可思议的戏。
And it starts as like regular over the shoulder and then it just cuts to you guys looking right into the can't. I love that. It was so effective as you're finishing this argument just right into the camera cutting back and forth directly. It was really cool. Oh, I can't wait. By the way, six minutes standing ovation at the Venice Film Festival.
一开始就像常规的过肩镜头，然后直接切到你们直视镜头的画面。我太喜欢了。当你们结束这场争论时，直接切到镜头前，来回切换，这太有效了。真的太酷了。哦，我等不及了。顺便说一句，在威尼斯电影节获得了六分钟的全场起立鼓掌。
Yeah? Yeah. Wow. Really amazing. People tried to sit down. and I was like, oh, no, no sitting. Don't be rude. I just loved it.
是吗？对。哇。真的太惊人了。人们试图坐下来，而我当时就想，哦，不，不准坐。别这么粗鲁。我太喜欢了。
Yeah, oh, I'm glad. Thank you. I'm glad you got to see it. Oh, Luca just texted me. How crazy. Wow. Crazy. Wow.
对，哦，我很高兴。谢谢。我很高兴你能看到它。哦，卢卡刚给我发了短信。太疯狂了。哇。疯狂。哇。
Tell him he's doing well. He must have felt us talking about him. Is it nice to launch a film at a festival like that as opposed to just sort of a standard kind of release where it just kind of comes out? I've never really had an experience like this before. So it's nice to do new things, you know, especially this. What do you mean?
告诉他他干得不错。他一定感觉到我们在谈论他了。在这样的电影节上首映一部电影，是不是比那种直接上映的常规发行方式感觉更好？我以前从未有过这样的体验。所以尝试新事物感觉很好，你知道的，尤其是这个。你什么意思？
What do you mean you have an experience? Well, I mean, I've never been to the Venice Film Festival for one thing. And I mean, I guess George and I went to Cannes a few years ago, but that was the first time I'd ever been to Cannes. Yeah. Oh, wow. Because on television, they all look so terrifying. Like, why would you want to put yourself.
你这话什么意思，说你没这种体验？嗯，我的意思是，首先我从未去过威尼斯电影节。而且我的意思是，我想乔治和我几年前去过戛纳，但那是我第一次去戛纳。对。哦，哇。因为在电视上，它们看起来都太吓人了。就像，你为什么想把自己置于那种境地。
there. Yeah. I agree. So if people say, oh, do you want to go to Cannes? No, thank you. Off season. Yeah, it just looks so terrifying.
在那里。对。我同意。所以如果人们问，哦，你想去戛纳吗？不，谢谢。淡季再去。对，这看起来太吓人了。
People screaming and... But what about all the glam and festivities of it all? Is that appealing just in the slightest playing dress-up and all that stuff? Once you say yes, like once you commit to it, then you have to have a sporting event mentality
人们尖叫着……但是那些所有的魅力和庆典活动呢？哪怕有一点点吸引力吗，比如玩变装游戏和所有这些事情？一旦你答应了——一旦你承诺要去，那么你必须有一种体育赛事般的心态
about it. You have to... You're going to have a... great time. Danny had on a tuxedo. I was just, it was great. That part was great.
来对待它。你必须……你会度过一段非常美好的时光。丹尼穿了一套燕尾服。我当时就觉得，太棒了。那部分太棒了。
One final question before we let you go, because we've taken up way too much for your time. What is the coolest or weirdest or amazing piece of memorabilia from any film? Have you kept anything that you love? That's a good question. That is a good question. Because there are also, there are so many iconic films. I try, I always forget.
在我们让你离开之前的最后一个问题，因为我们占用了你太多时间了。任何电影中最酷、最诡异或最了不起的纪念品是什么？你有没有留存什么你深爱的东西？这是一个好问题。这确实是一个好问题。因为还有，有那么多标志性的电影。我试着……我总是忘。
Not contaminated soil from Aaron Brockovich, Shirley. But no, water samples, no. But I haven't done anything cool, like a... Or a costume or like a shirt or anything. I have a lot of costumes. I have a lot of costumes. Yeah. And somewhere I actually think I have some wedding dresses from Runaway Bride.
不是来自《永不妥协》（Erin Brockovich）的受污染土壤，雪莉。但不是，水样，没有。但我没做过什么酷炫的事，比如……或者戏服，或者是衬衫之类的。我有好多戏服。我有很多戏服。对。而且在某个地方，我其实觉得我有一些来自《逃跑的新娘》（Runaway Bride）的婚纱。
Oh, wow. Yeah. Do you have a place you keep them? I mean, like a separate from your... It's probably dangerously just in the garage in New Mexico. And maybe there's just generations of mice that have made homes now that they're trying it on. They're each trying it on. In these boxes.
哦，哇。是啊。你有专门存放它们的地方吗？我是说，比如一个独立于你……它可能非常危险地就放在新墨西哥州的车库里。也许现在里面已经有好几代老鼠安了家，它们正在试穿。它们每个人都在试穿。在这些箱子里。
Yeah. Yeah, but not really more like I have a beautiful drawing that Merrill Streep did for me of my character that she gave me as a rap gift from August O'Sage County. Oh, I love that movie. That movie's so good. Some things like that. What a cast. Eat your fish. George produced that movie.
对。对，但其实没有，更准确地说，我有梅丽尔·斯特里普（Meryl Streep）为我画的一幅精美的我的角色画像，那是她作为《八月：奥色治郡》（August: Osage County）的杀青礼物送给我的。哦，我喜欢那部电影。那部电影太棒了。有诸如此类的东西。多棒的演员阵容啊。吃你的鱼。乔治制作了那部电影。
Yeah, eat fish, bitch. George Clooney produced that movie. Oh, yeah. Oh, that's great. Mm-hmm. Yeah, it's very good. Okay, so it premieres. So it's called After the Hunt.
对，吃鱼吧，贱人。乔治·克鲁尼制作了那部电影。哦，对。哦，太棒了。嗯哼。对，非常棒。好吧，所以它要首映了。所以片名叫《猎场》。
It premieres, wait, select theaters October 10th and wider October 17th. It's so good. I mean, I just loved it. I loved it so much. Thank you. Julia, you're the greatest. Yeah, no kidding. You guys are so fun.
它首映，等等，10月10日部分影院上映，10月17日全面上映。太棒了。我是说，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。谢谢。朱莉娅，你是最棒的。对，说真的。你们太有趣了。
I honestly, this is just, just zipped by and I was quick right I just want I want a chance to do it again and and and be quick and witty and and and you were no you were sublime on one of the one of the dudes no you are you are you were amazing come back anytime you want can we just talk about the microphone that Will Arnett has in his apartment yeah it's pretty sweet what is up with that it's nice it's janky right now I'm in a very I'm in a make-shift situation because I just moved in here yesterday. the whisper booth all set up, huh?
老实说，这简直——一晃就过去了，而且我很敏捷对吧？我只是——我想要一个机会再来一次，而且要敏捷机智——而你也是，不，你无与伦比，作为众多硬汉之一——不，你——你太棒了。随时欢迎回来。我们能聊聊威廉·阿奈特（Will Arnett）公寓里的那个麦克风吗？对，相当不错，那是怎么回事？挺好的，它现在有点破烂，对吧？我目前处于一个非常简陋的状况，因为我昨天刚搬进这里。隔音亭还没弄好呢，对吧？
I know, I know. It's not, nothing's great. The internet's not great. I got the windows open because the AC's broken. I got a guy here. You got a real vital VO career you need to manage. Don't we get to see?
我知道，我知道。它不好，什么都不好。网络不好。我把窗户开着，因为空调坏了。我这里有个修理工。你可有一个非常重要的配音（VO）职业需要管理呢。难道我们看不到？
Oh, those chairs are nice. Yeah. Do we get to see your guest star? Yeah. Where's your babe? Let's pull your babe in real quick. She just went out. She just went out.
哦，那些椅子真不错。是啊。我们能看到你的特邀嘉宾吗？对。你的宝贝呢？快把你的宝贝拉过来露个面。她刚出去。她刚出去。
Oh, sure. Oh, she's just went out. Just left. Yeah. I think it's all fake. I think what you guys. Yeah, it's like a, it's a fake media story. No, we're thrilled for you.
哦，当然。哦，她刚出去。刚离开。对。我觉得这都是假的。我觉得你们俩……对，这就像一个假的新闻故事。不，我们为你感到高兴。
Yeah, we are thrilled. Julia, thank you so much. Thank you for saying yes to this. Talk about a thrill. Come back anytime you want, Mrs. Oh, thanks. Thank you. It goes without saying, I've been such a fan of yours for so long.
对，我们太高兴了。朱莉娅，非常感谢你。谢谢你答应接受采访。真是一次极大的兴奋。随时欢迎回来，夫人。哦，谢谢。谢谢。不用说，我一直是你的超级粉丝，已经很久很久了。
Likewise. You're so great at what you do. Yes. Thank you. More, please. Truly. Thank you. And can I just say, I'm sorry to leave you out, Sean, because I am your guest and I appreciate you so much.
彼此彼此。你在你的领域里太优秀了。是的。谢谢。请多来一点。真的。谢谢。我能说吗，我很抱歉把你漏掉了，肖恩，因为我是你的嘉宾，我非常感激你。
That's okay, likewise. But arrested development. Danny and I ate that show up like ice cream and I'm happy to report that our youngest son who's 18 just started college episode one pilot who just started all over again me and him together
没关系，彼此彼此。但是《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）。丹尼和我把那部剧像冰淇淋一样吃得精光，我很高兴地向你们汇报，我们18岁的小儿子刚刚开始上大学，第一集，试播集，他刚刚又重新开始看，我和他一起
we are loving it Can you invite me over? Because I haven't seen them since then and I want to watch them all again and my kids won't watch anything I do. Come over. We'll go back to the pilot. We will back this right up. Jason and I haven't watched.
我们爱极了。你能邀请我去你家吗？因为我从那以后就没看过它们了，我想把它们全都重温一遍，而我的孩子们不肯看我演的任何东西。来吧。我们从试播集看起。我们将倒回开头。杰森和我还没看过。
We used to watch when it first came on the air. I'd go over Sundays. We'd watch football together and we'd watch the episodes as it aired. We were like, wow, this is so crazy. Yeah, and then we'd wake up in the morning and we'd call in for the overnights. It is so... How much is going on all the time is...
我们以前在它刚开播的时候看。我会过去过星期天。我们一起看橄榄球，并在剧集播出时观看。当时我们觉得，哇，这太疯狂了。对，然后我们会在早晨醒来，打电话询问收视率。这真是……随时都在发生那么多事情……
It's extraordinary. Well, you know Mitch Hurwitz. Julia, I know you know Mitch a little bit. And I just spoke to for the first time in a few months. Two days go out of the blue. How's he doing? He's doing okay, yeah. He's the funniest guy.
这太不可思议了。嗯，你知道米奇·赫维茨（Mitch Hurwitz）。朱莉娅，我知道你对米奇略知一二。我刚刚在几个月内第一次和他通话。两天前突然联系了。他过得怎么样？他过得还行，对。他是最搞笑的人。
Immediately you start texting with him and he's the funniest person of all time. I mean, that show really is one in a million. Sean's going to catch it one of these days. We're going to get some tapes, Sean. We're going to make him watch it clock record, though. Yeah. Well, thank you, Julia, for being with us today.
你一和他发短信，他就是有史以来最搞笑的人。我是说，那部剧真的是千里挑一。肖恩总有一天会看到的。我们要弄到一些磁带，肖恩。我们要让他看着钟表记录下来再看。好吧。好吧，谢谢你，朱莉娅今天和我们在一起。
Enjoy the rest of your day. And good luck with the film. Thanks. After the hunt. Can't wait. Coming in October. Off to the Hunt. October 10th, wide, October 17th.
祝你今天剩余时间过得愉快。祝你的电影大获成功。谢谢。《猎场》。迫不及待了。十月上映。前往猎场。10月10日，全面上映，10月17日。
My birthday, October 28th. Oh, great. That's my eldest. That's Frannie's birthday, my eldest. October, it's the, it's the big month now. It's three days after my son Archie and Wendell Clark's birthday. Okay, it doesn't matter. It's like three and a half months and a couple weeks out of minute.
我的生日，10月28日。哦，太棒了。那是我的大孩子。那是弗兰尼（Frannie）的生日，我的大孩子。十月，现在是个大月份。那是我的儿子阿奇（Archie）和温德尔·克拉克（Wendel Clark）生日的三天后。好吧，这不重要。大概是三点半个月再过几周吧。
Anyway, so, I love you to pieces. Thank you for being your honor. Lots of love, you guys. Thank you. Bye. Bye. Wow, Sean. Isn't she great?
不管怎样，我爱死你了。谢谢你成为我们的荣耀。祝你们一切都好，伙计们。谢谢。再见。再见。哇，肖恩。她是不是很棒？
I love, by the way, for so long, she's been on my list. I'm sure she's on the dollar list. Tip top. Yeah, of every list. I know. I know. I mean the list, she's at the top of the week. I was looking at her list of credits, and you're just like, bang, bang, bang, bang, one big movie after another.
顺便说一句，我一直很喜欢她，她一直在我的名单上。我确信她在美元榜上也是名列前茅。顶尖。是的，在每一个名单上。我知道。我知道。我是指那个名单，她每周都排在最前面。我刚刚查看了她的演艺经历名单，你会发现，砰、砰、砰、砰，一部接一部的大制作电影。
It's just, um... It has even taken pauses, you know, as she's elected to take pauses and the industry just, just, keeps her place in line. And she comes back in and she's just bang, another incredible director she works with. Yeah.
这只是，嗯……甚至连她选择暂停的时候，你知道的，当她选择休息时，这个行业也只是——只是为她保留着位置。然后她又回来了，砰，又是和另一位不可思议的导演合作。是的。
You know, it's an incredible career. Yeah, and that movie's really good. Yeah, that's... I can't wait to see that movie. It's not... It's not in the English countryside chasing foxes on horses, right? No, this is not...
你知道，这是一段不可思议的职业生涯。是的，那部电影真的很棒。是的，那是……我等不及要看那部电影了。它不是——它不是那种在英国乡村骑着马追逐狐狸的电影，对吧？不，这不是……
None of that's happening now. It's not about a salon after the hunt where we're sitting in the drawing room talking about the hunt. Wonderful shot back then, James. What a hunt we had, eh? Oh, that's tricky little fox. Tricky little fox.
现在可没有那些了。这不是关于狩猎后我们在客厅里坐着谈论狩猎的沙龙。詹姆斯，那时候拍得真好。我们进行了一次多么棒的狩猎啊，对吧？哦，那只狡猾的小狐狸。狡猾的小狐狸。
Yeah, what else can you say? I was going to ask her about being called America's sweetheart because she's been called that for her whole life and what that means. Like, if she hates that anymore, you know, it's like it's true. Everybody, there's nobody that doesn't love her. Right, but it's also like you can hate it, but like it is something maybe you could look back on
是的，你还能说什么呢？我本来想问她关于被称为“美国甜心”的事，因为她一辈子都被这么叫，这究竟意味着什么。比如，她是否还讨厌这个称呼，你知道的，这就好像是真的。每个人，没有一个人不爱她。对，但这也就像你可以讨厌它，但这也许是一件你可以回首往事的事，
when you're, you know, lying on the bed, taking your last 25 breaths and going to like, that was pretty cool that I held that title, you know? Yeah, I mean, for so long. She's awesome. And there's other friends of ours that has that title as well. There are those that share it, for sure. I share it. Well, hang on.
当你在，你知道的，躺在床上，做着最后25次呼吸的时候，心里会想，我拥有过这个头衔，真的很酷，对吧？对，我是说，维持了这么久。她太棒了。我们还有其他朋友也拥有这个头衔。确实有人分享这个头衔。我也分享。等等。
So many people. No, I don't know. Who's thinking of a bye? You know, well, you're Googling something. Let's see what you found. So I just, I just loved her story. Don't worry about that she kept the dresses from a runaway. Bye!
太多人了。不，我不知道。谁在想再见？你知道的，好吧，你在用谷歌搜索什么。让我们看看你找到了什么。所以我就——我只是太喜欢她保留了《逃跑的新娘》里的裙子的那个故事了。再见！
Bye! smart less There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见！SmartLess 本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。